plus on utilise des antibiotiques plus
ils tendent à perdre leur efficacité
1975 des médecins a alerté sur les
conséquences de la surconsommation
d'antibiotiques
certaines bactéries sont tellement
accoutumés à l'antibiotique et qu'elles
en ont besoin
les ans sont dépendantes elles ne
peuvent se multiplier qu'en présence de
l'antibiotique vous voyez que dans le
monde bactérien
il est aussi des toxiques hommes à cette
époque la résistance aux antibiotiques
étaient déjà un problème majeur de santé
publique
pour le docteur maurice rapin qui n'a
cessé d'alerter sur le risque d'une
meilleure communication autour de ces
médicaments étaient alors primordial il
est donc nécessaire que le public
restreignent sont un poids des
antibiotiques en supprimant
l'automédication et d'autre part qu'il
n'incite pas les médecins à user
précocément très précocement
d'antibiotiques
malgré ces recommandations 19 ans plus
tard la surconsommation d'antibiotiques
est toujours un problème en france
les français sont de grands
consommateurs de médicaments parfois
deux à trois fois plus que leurs voisins
notamment pour les antibiotiques ou
encore les antidépresseurs en 2000 dans
une étude
un groupe de médecins tirer encore une
fois la sonnette d'alarmé
ils s'inquiétaient de l'inefficacité des
antibiotiques notamment sur les enfants
contre l'abus d'antibiotiques ces
professionnels de la santé vont se
rendre dans les cabinets médicaux les
pharmacies les crèches pour une campagne
de sensibilisation en 2002 l'assurance
maladie lance est aussi une campagne
nationale de sensibilisation une
campagne au slogan efficace
les antibiotiques c'est pas automatique
parlez-en avec votre médecin
depuis 2000 la consommation
d'antibiotiques a diminué en france
mais la résistance à ces médicaments
fait toujours des dégâts selon lagence
du médicament près de cent soixante
mille personnes développent une
infection liée à une bactérie
multirésistante et plus de 12 mille cinq
cents personnes en meurent chaque année
[Musique]